In the last two videos, we've been slowly
building up our aggregate
demand-aggregate supply
model and the whole point of us doing this
is so that we can give
an explanation of why we have these
short run economic cycles
and we don't just have
this nice steady march
of economic growth due to
population increases and
productivity improvement.
It's important to
realize and it's probably
important to realize this
for all of what we study
in micro and macro economics
that this is really
just a model.
In order for to use
these models, we have to
make huge, huge
simplifications and you really
should always view these models with a
critical eye.
This is just one way to view it.
You might not agree with it.
You might think it's
an over simplification.
You might want to modify it in some way.
It's very important that
you just view it only
as a model and the reason
why we do that is so
that we can start to
describe very, very, very
complicated things with
fairly simple graphs
and mathematics so that
we can get our brain
around something as
complicated as the economy.
Something that has hundreds
of millions of actors,
each of them with tens
of billions of neurons
in their brain and doing
all sorts of crazy things.
We're able to distill
it down to simple lines
and curves and equations.
Now in the last video,
we looked a little bit at
the long run aggregate supply.
Aggregate supply in the long run.
In the ADAS model, we
assumed that in the long run,
the real productivity
of the economy really
doesn't depend on price,
that price is really just
a numeric thing and in
the long run, people will
just adjust to producing
or the economy will
what it's capable of
comfortably producing.
Now there's one thing
I want to stress here.
This is not the maximum
productivity of the economy.
You could view this as the natural;
let me put it this way.
You could view this as the,
so this right over here,
you could view it as the natural output.
Natural, the natural real
output of the economy.
When I say natural, it means that there's
always going to be some
inefficiencies in the
economy; people are going
to be switching jobs.
They might have to retrain.
There's always going to
be turnover in things.
Some people pass away
in a job and then they
have to hire other people.
There's some normal or natural rate of
unemployment.
In most economies, people aren't working
night and day.
They want to take some time off.
They want to be able to rest.
Because of other
interventions, there aren't
perfect efficiencies in
the economy as a whole.
This is just a natural
healthy level of output.
There is some theoretical level of output.
I'll draw that here.
This is maybe some
theoretical level of output
that you could maybe
view as maximum output.
Maybe I'll draw it right over here.
This right over here
might be maximum output.
Maximum, given the population and the
technology that the population has,
this is some type of
theoretical thing and it
would be very hard to actually quantify.
People were just working all out.
They weren't taking vacations.
They weren't sleeping properly.
Every person was working in the place that
they could be the most
productive, then maybe
you would have some
output over here which is
kind of impossible to achieve.
This is something below
that, kind of a nice
healthy level of output for the economy.
Now what we're going to
talk about in this video
is aggregate supply in
the short run and what
we're going to see is
for this model to work,
for the aggregate
demand-aggregate supply model
to work, we have to
assume an upward sloping
aggregate supply curve in the short run.
It might look something like this.
It might look something
like this and obviously,
it would; actually let me do it this way.
Let's assume that this
is our current level of
prices are sitting right over here.
This is our long run aggregate supply.
It's not depending on
prices; it's just a natural
level of output, but in
the short run it might
look something like this.
I'll do it in pink.
In the short run, it might
look something like this.
As I'm toting it up
because obviously we can
never get past that
optimal, so what's going on
here, what's going on in this curve -
I drew a dotted line because
it's easier for me to
draw something as a
dotted line when I draw
it as a straight curve.
My hand always shakes too
much - so this is the
aggregate supply in the
short run.
We'll see we need it to
be upward sloping for
this model to provide
a basis of explanation
for economic cycles
and there's a couple of
explanations or a couple
of, you could really
view them as theories,
for why we can justify
an upward sloping aggregate supply curve.
The one way to think
about it and before I even
justify why it could be
upward sloping, what an
upward sloping curve is
saying is look, this is
just when people are nicely
... They're producing
at their natural rate.
There's going to be
some unemployment in the
economy at this level right over here.
For whatever reason, this
upward curve is saying
if prices go up, if prices go up, then the
economy as a whole is
going to produce beyond
that natural rate.
Maybe it's going to bring
in people from other
parts or I guess you
could say it's going to
suck people in to the
labor pool who might not
have been in the labor
pool to work a little
bit harder.
Maybe they feel they can
do a little bit better now.
It might convince factories
to run a little bit
longer.
It might convince people
to take fewer vacations.
The opposite might be
true if prices go down.
An upward sloping curve
is saying that if prices,
aggregate prices - Now
this isn't just prices
in one good or service
- if aggregate price is
going down, it's saying
in the economy as a whole
people might be incented
to work a little bit less.
People might drop out of the labor pool.
In the short run, remember
this is all in the
short run, they might drop
out of the labor pool.
They might not run
their factories all out.
They might take more
vacations, whatever else.
Now let's think about what our plausible
justifications for an
upward sloping aggregate
supply curve.
The first one is often
called the misperception
theory; let me write it in white.
It's the misperception
theory and it kind of makes
sense to me that if the
aggregate; let's think
about a situation where
the aggregate prices are
going up.
Aggregate prices are going up.
If I'm an individual
actor there, maybe I run
a firm of some kind, I
might not notice immediately
that it's aggregate
prices that are going up.
I might just think that
prices for my goods or
services are going up.
I might think that it's actually a micro
economic phenomenon going on.
I'm misperceiving it
as a micro phenomenon.
That's something that's
going on in my market.
If I think and this goes
back to the micro economics,
if I think that prices for
my goods and services are
going up relative to others and remember
this is a misperception,
all prices are going up,
but if I think this is
happening in the short run then the law of
supply kicks in.
Then the law of supply kicks in which is a
micro economic concept that if I feel that
real prices - And it's
not real prices. It's
actually nominal prices
- but if I think my
relative prices are
increasing, I'm motivated
to produce more.
I think I'm going to be more profitable.
It only takes a little
bit of time for me to
realize that all my costs are going up,
what I can purchase
with my profits are all
going up.
In real terms, I'm actually
not getting any better
and then I'll probably
settle in back to my
regular level of productivity.
While I think people are
demanding more of Sal's
sprockets or whatever
I'm seeing, I'll start
working over time.
I might want to hire more
people, run the factories
beyond even a level that
I might defer maintenance
so that I can run the
factories longer and all
the rest, but then over
time I'm going to realize
that I was just misperceiving things.
Everything has gotten more expensive.
I'm not making in real
terms an outsized profit
right now.
Then my level of productivity
might actually go back.
When I talk about me,
it's not me by myself
that's moving this whole economy.
Remember I'm just talking
about one actor, but this
might be true of many,
many, many actors in
acting in aggregate so
as a whole, they might
want to increase productivity
and then when they
realize that in real
terms they're actually not
making any more money and that this isn't
sustainable, they'll go
back to their natural
level of output.
The other theory that you'll read about in
economic textbooks, another
theory or explanation
or justification why
we would have an upward
sloping aggregate supply
curve in the short run
is sometimes it's called
the sticky wages theory.
Sticky wages.
I like to extend it to sticky cost theory.
Sometimes they'll
articulate a separate one
called sticky prices,
but in my mind these are
all very similar, so sticky
wages, sticky costs and
sticky prices.
Sticky, sticky prices.
It's the general idea
that even if in aggregate
prices are increasing,
so in the whole economy
prices are increasing, in
all parts of the economy
they all won't increase at the same rate.
There are parts of the economy
where the prices might
be stickier than other
places and there's multiple reasons why
prices could be sticky.
You could have wage
contracts or people might
just be slow to realize
prices are going up
and then renegotiating their contracts.
You might have long term
agreements with suppliers
that you're going to
pay a fixed price over
some period of time.
You've already agreed for the next year
to pay it so even if aggregate prices
are going up, it's
going to take a while in
different parts of the
economy, for contracts
or for transactions in
those parts of the economy,
to actually reflect those things.
Another reason why in
parts of the economy you
might not have everything
move in tandem or
everything move as quickly
as you would expect
is because of something called menu costs.
Menu costs.
Menu costs are just the
idea that if prices are
changing, if prices move
up in the next hour 5%,
it's not actually trivial to increase your
prices by 5%.
For example, if you were
running a restaurant,
you would have to reprint
new menus, so that's
where the name comes from,
but it's not just true
of a restaurant; it's true of anything.
It would be true if you're
any type of supplier.
You would have to change your brochures.
You might have to change
your computer systems.
You have to do a ton of
things to actually make
things; you have to tell your sales force
how the pricing might be different.
There's a ton of things
that you have to do to
actually change costs.
These menu costs actually
might slow down the
ability for all prices to move in tandem.
Some of them will be
stickier than others and
the reason why this is can be a rationale
for an upward sloping
aggregate supply curve
in the short run is if I'm in one of these
industries, let's say
my sales I am able to
raise the prices but
let's say the wages and my
costs are sticky.
I've already got into a
long term wage contract
and all my suppliers
can't raise their prices
as fast, so in the short
run I'm going to say gee,
I'm making a lot of profit now.
Even in real terms
because my costs are being
relatively sticky, while
the money that's coming
in the door I'm able
to raise the prices so
I'm going to produce more.
I'm going to run the factories longer.
Maybe I'll defer maintenance so that I can
produce more.
Maybe I'll try to hire
more people under these
agreements.
Maybe I'll try to buy
more goods and services
under these long term costs.
The reason why I say
these are really the same
side of the same coin
is you can imagine here
you have company A that
is able to increase
its prices so its revenue
starts going up and
let's say its supplier is company B.
It's company B and this
right over here is sticky.
This is sticky.
Maybe A buys lemons from B and then sells
lemonade.
It's able to raise the price of lemonade,
but it has a fixed price
contract on the lemons
in the short run.
Eventually that will expire,
in the long run B will
be able to renegotiate it upwards.
A's costs are sticky, but this is B's
prices are sticky.
These are really the same
thing that one's costs
are really the other's prices.